yo uh another situation that you were
part of earlier this year that kind of
went viral was uh you and the STG kind
of have like a public spat because you
didn't like that he was going to charge
you I think it was 50k for a verse right
oh man 75. 75
that's cool you because they're like hey
well he doesn't know you this what he
charges like it is what it is but you
guys kind of got past that like
um did was there anything you took from
that situation really
um you know I mean um I had to really
come with artists you know I mean
nowadays with the new artists I guess
with like features and stuff because you
know I look I was I was the dude in the
game that's what I'm saying I ain't the
number one Diamond records like we going
up man connects to Kanye West we we
selling out Arenas we doing we doing
things I wasn't really charging people
like that you were doing [ __ ] like a lot
on the strength if you [ __ ] with them if
you know what I mean like we've seen
each other I'm a fan of you all like I
see your work yo let's put something
together we just on the planet and this
is the hip-hop culture just making music
so I think you know just the supporters
outside you know they like to see like
collaborations yeah and I just was
trying to put something together so you
know what I mean where that's all yeah
thank you